victoria what's going on i should
preface this call by saying
i'm not suicidal however
i'm not laughing i i don't know who i'm
i'm not laughing at you laughing with
you
like man not funny remember no it's not
funny i'm just the number of times i've
had that a conversation prefaced with
that in my career has been a lot and it
always
the follow-up is here we go all right so
i got my uh
i got my i don't know my
hard conversation held on let's do this
all right so you're not suicidal but
but i have a lot of suicidal thoughts
while i'm doing just super mundane
things and they come
just super random like i'll be driving
and i'm thinking i just so badly want to
just swerve my car and crash oh and i
need to pick up peanut butter
yeah okay so give me another example
yeah so sometimes when i'm doing dishes
i'll be putting them away and i'll pick
up a knife
and i just think like okay what if i
just stabbed myself with this right now
like everything would be
over and done with and i'd be okay with
that and then i put it away
and like feed my baby okay it's just
super random
and yeah what can i do to
control that or like would that classify
me as suicidal like what
i'm just i need help number one
thank you for trusting me with this this
one um
like beyond like i hear i hear you're
somebody that approaches hard
conversations with laughter right
i'm i'm a similar way are there moments
when this has scared you
oh absolutely yes okay all right so
uh transitioning from me laughing and
carrying on and
understanding like these are this is a
scary thing so
um what i want to tell you i'm grateful
for yours brave for you to call
most people in your situation that i've
worked with over the years
man they think they start to think
they're crazy right they think they're
nuts and i think i'm wrong with them
and that if they will just speak this
out loud someone's going to take away
their baby someone's going to
institutionalize them or whatever is
next right
so it's brave that you called and i
appreciate that
when you i'm going to walk you through
something i'm going to start this whole
thing off with
the idea that you have these intrusive
thoughts is the way the nerds say them
right
so these are lightning bolts that just
shoot into your mind they just
pop in there and you will go whoa right
that's not nuts happens to everybody
intrusive thoughts about self-harm
particularly in moments where you could
actually do it like it's not like you're
just walking around the thing at target
and you're like man if i had a knife i
could just stab myself
it's when you're holding it right i'm
gonna tell you those aren't abnormal but
they're not great
right they're not healthy and so i want
to get some more information from you so
where if you had to just mine your life
right mind the life that's victoria
where are they from how long have they
happened
where do you think these have shown up
that's a great question so i was
actually thinking about this the other
day
and they've been going on for as long as
i can remember the
first time that i can actually remember
i was probably like
nine or ten like it like the thought
just popped in my head but i kept it to
myself because i'm like oh everybody
must have these thoughts
it wasn't until recently that they
started getting
worse and i actually started like
formulating oh what if i did exactly
this
like that i started thinking maybe i
should talk to somebody
yeah yeah so how old's your baby
she is one one okay did you have any
postpartum with this baby
i probably i just was never treated
okay okay so tell me about um
growing up did you experience trauma as
a kid
yes my mom is an alcoholic okay
um some verbal and sexual abuse as well
okay just a lot of things that no kid
should go through i went through you're
exactly right yeah
has when you were pregnant when you
found out you were pregnant and over the
arc of your pregnancy
did that stuff circle up more than it
normally has
no just say mold same old were you
excited to be pregnant yeah yes my
husband
she was she was planned so we were very
happy when we found out that we were
pregnant
very cool all right so in in your
like let's i'm just going to pick one up
where do you work
yes okay so you're at work how do you
handle a a stressful customer or if your
boss has to have a hard conversation
with you
and have to talk to you like how do you
handle that
well i actually just started my job
yesterday so i haven't had to deal with
that
you cope with challenges and it really
just depends on what the challenge is i
try to remain calm
but sometimes i just i get so angry
and i just have to walk away okay like
i'm just not able to
to hide how upset i am that they're
upset with me
have you ever tried to hurt yourself
before yes
okay have you ever made a suicide
attempt before
kind of okay what's that mean um
one time i did actually crash my car
okay intentionally
yes and no i was going 55 i saw gravel
and i just slammed on my brakes on
gravel gravel and twisted my wheel
potentially like swerving it like i
don't know if i had the intention of
like
doing any harm but i would consider that
yeah
yeah have you ever yeah have you ever um
have you ever struggled with uh
disordered eating or
self-cutting yourself no no okay
um have you ever been diagnosed with any
mental health issues
so i've been to a couple of counselors
through the years and i
i just i've never liked any of them one
said that i was bipolar
another said that i was depressed
another said
that i just needed to practice gratitude
and geez so i just
just just light a candle and take a warm
bath that'll fix it right
almighty just all over the place so i
just i don't
i didn't trust any of those because it
would be one session and they're like ah
you're
you're obviously bipolar and i'm like
but am i though yeah
so tell me about your friends your
community that you hang out with people
that you go to when things get
bananas uh so i
we've actually just moved to nashville
not too long ago
with kovid we really haven't like been
able to
hang out with a whole lot of people but
we are in a church back up before
mecca before nashville did you have a um
a gang where you came from
yeah yeah i had a couple of close
friends from work
when you say close friends from work
there are people that you went and had
drinks with or people that you
have talked about your childhood trauma
with
um no i never really talked to anybody
about
my childhood okay and so that would be
my differentiation of friend versus
buddies at work
friend is somebody that can be i could
tell the good things to
a friend is someone i can tell the bad
things like when i violate my values
right
and a friend is someone i can tell who's
hurt me in my past
and do you not have those folks like i
have i have my husband
right you got your yeah you've got your
your husband
beyond him yeah i actually i do have a
really close friend
that i do talk with on a regular basis
what
is it she yes would she know about these
things
these thoughts that you have yeah i
actually just opened up to her
about it not too long ago gotcha
so here's here's my
here this is not for what it's worth
okay
um having intrusive thoughts
is it happens to everybody okay
especially especially i walk through
several things here
folks with with sexual abuse physical
abuse emotional boost
from childhood folks with no
friends or with a small community and
a perceived burdensomeness and this
means
i bring a room down when i hang out with
folks or i'm not going to tell them it's
just going to ruin their day
and people begin to feel like they are a
burden to other folks and you'll see
this with kids you'll see this with
you know adults like my kids would be
better off without me
my husband would just be better off if
or i'm so exhausted and worn out and it
would be better if
fill in the blank right um
then there becomes this escalating
thoughts
right so my favorite dr joyner who's my
favorite
suicide researcher talks about
practice and it can be
risky behaviors it can be cutting it can
be speeding a car and
peeling out just before something bad
happens
and it can also be an escalation of
practicing thoughts right
so it goes from man if i was just not
here
to i'm holding this knife i could just
right
which turns into i'm just gonna cut
myself a little bit which turns into
oh man that relieved some pain i'm gonna
cut myself again which
is an escalation right so all those
things it would tell me
is this you've got a little girl
you have a little you said that right
little girl yeah
okay you would be somebody that i would
say if you were my friend hanging out at
my house and we're just sitting on the
front porch having barbecue
and your husband's over my wife's over
and we're cooking hanging out and you
told me what you just told me
i would tell you you need to go see
somebody
you need to go talk to a counselor who
you're going to be plugged in with for
the long haul
and they're going to really frustrate
you they're going to annoy you
they're going to drive you bananas but
they're also going to teach you
some new tools on how to handle these
thoughts
if and when they begin to increase
because my guess is these thoughts are
one of several hard coping strategies
what's something else that
you how you process things how you
interact with the world that you don't
tell other people
i know they're there i get
i just i shut people out like sometimes
i'll intentionally
get angry with my husband over silly
things
to avoid talking about other things that
are bothering me why do you do that
because i i just i just don't want to
talk about some things and i feel like
you just wouldn't
understand because we come from very
different backgrounds
and give me an example of something that
he wants to talk about that you just
you bail out on i don't want to talk
about
well sometimes when i when i am having
like some of those
those suicide or suicidal thoughts
and he asks he's like hey what's wrong
and i'm like nothing
like i just don't want him to worry i
don't want him to
go to work and then thinking that he's
going to come home to a dead wife
right i just don't want him to worry
about that because they're not
his problems and so when he
looked you in the eye and said i do they
became his problems
and he will go to work and he will worry
about you
and he will develop scenarios and then
he'll try to solve those scenarios that
may or may not be accurate
and over time his attempts to re-bridge
that
gap that connection that that
disconnection that he feels from you
is going to get harder and wider does
that make sense
yeah and so i know you were trying to
take care of the people around you
that's what i would mean by perceived
burdensomeness these aren't his problems
these are mine i'm just going to sit on
them and be quiet
and you got a guy that told the universe
i'm going to be with you forever
and you don't want to put stuff in his
backpack that he's got to carry
to work with him right that's the
perceived burdensomeness
that's when i would tell you yes you
were walking down
a like a path in the woods and i don't
like the direction that you're heading
does that make sense
and you are too smart and you are too
lovely of a mom
and a wife to not value yourself in the
way that that little girl does the way
your husband does and the way other
people
would if you would let them in
who hurt you as a kid
i was a grandfather okay
did mom and dad know did they go to war
on your behalf do they cover it up how
are they involved
they covered it up okay so here's what
you got in your heart
and more specifically in the tiny little
part of your brain that's now spidered
across your entire
neurology is the most
important thing to you as a child is the
safety
that comes from your parents
relationship extended to your
grandparents
and that relationship was severed at a
young young age
it's a fireplace right and
what your brain knows is if you get too
close
to somebody else they're going to hurt
you too
and it would rather make sure you avoid
that close connection that you should
have got from them
it wants you to avoid it because man
we're not going through that again that
hurt and we will never do that again
and so you end up with a a
man you love your husband don't you yeah
he's a safe guy to you absolutely
yeah he is not fully in though is he
no
what about that baby girl
what about her like you love her too
right oh yes of course
does it freak you out or make you whole
at how much he loves you
or how much he needs you
kind of freaks me out
no because like i do like you were
saying like i often think that
she would be better off like if she had
another mom
okay so victoria she wouldn't be
she's best off with you
and as i'm saying that if your first
impulse your first thought is
yeah you don't know me or
whatever if that's your first thought i
want you to hear me say
you need to go talk to somebody
will you promise me that you will
i was afraid you were going to say that
yes i promise here's who deserves it in
this order
number one you you've been carrying too
much crap
in your backpack and your heart for way
too long
and i want you to sit with somebody who
over a period of time
and hey you got a lot of junk back there
it's gonna take a season
okay and
over time you will walk taller and you
will walk
um stronger than you even knew you were
capable of
you've heard me use that analogy bricks
in your backpack what you don't realize
is when they start taking those bricks
out when you start processing those and
feeling those and then
taking them out and setting them down
you don't realize how strong you've
become
carrying them around and suddenly when
those things aren't in your backpack
anymore
you realize i am a force to be reckoned
with in this world
and you find a strength that you didn't
know you had because somebody else had
had dropped cinder blocks in your back
listen to me
your granddad shouldn't have done that
and your mom and dad shouldn't have let
that crap happen
and you deserved somebody to go to war
on your behalf and they didn't and i'm
so sorry
and now you've got a husband who loves
you
he doesn't even know how cause he's
trying
you got a baby girl that's dependent on
you and you're
a extraordinary woman here in my
hometown who's worth being well
and the beautiful thing that i can tell
you about nashville
is there's some world-class all-star
folks that can walk alongside this with
you
if you'll let them
and so i'll ask you again you promise
you'll go see somebody
yes okay i promise will you bring your
husband into this let him listen to this
episode
and in fact it's this there's usually
delay here we'll see if we can get you
an earlier cut okay as soon as we can
and this will give you an entry point to
talk with him okay
okay and i want you to know that your
bravery today
there are gonna be thousands if not tens
of thousands of people
listening to this who have those
intrusive thoughts they just
hush them away they don't want to burden
their wife with them they don't want to
burden their
their best friend with them so they just
sit on them and sit on them
and they escalate and they get tougher
and they get tougher
and the voices get louder and louder and
as your daughter gets closer and closer
to the age you were
when the crap happened to you as a kid
starts
those voices will get louder and louder
and so by you taking the first step that
i'm making the call i'm so proud of you
the next step that i want you to do
today is to reach out to somebody
and i want you to not just go once and
be like oh they sucked it
go again and then i want you to go again
and i want you to go again
and i want you to start that
conversation with
i'm having suicidal thoughts i'm not
going to hurt myself i don't have a plan
i have no
imminent danger i'm a childhood abuse
survivor my parents didn't step up when
they should have i've got a one-year-old
daughter i got a husband who loves me
i need to learn how to let this stuff i
need to be able to set it down
i need to heal and i need to learn some
new tools
and if they say well you know you need
to have a warm bath walk out walk out
smile say bye felicia i'm out and then
walk out
and then go to the next and i promise
you there's some great folks here in
this city
i've met with them myself right thank
you so much for that call
anybody out there
anybody out there if you are thinking
about hurting yourself
if you're thinking my husband my wife my
kids my work
would be better off with me not here
even if it's not an immediate emergency
i want you to call the national suicide
prevention lifeline
1-800-273-8255
or you can text the crisis line you can
text home
to 741 741 that's not a
ramsey-affiliated
group it doesn't have anything to do
with us this is a national hotline for
folks who are
thinking i'm going to hurt myself today
right i'm going to take my life today
i'm going to attempt to step out today
text
home to 741-741 24 hours a day
seven days a week please and if somebody
in your world
says man i think i hurt myself get them
the help that they need
call on the calvary if you got to we are
all in this one together
all of us are in this together and we're
gonna heal together too
as couples as friends as communities as
a country
thank you for being brave victoria i
appreciate it let us know how those that
first
session goes and we'll check in with you